what was your proudest moment as an
actor all right I took a dramatic pause
but I knew the answer right away very
easy so the first big prime-time Network
show that I got that I booked a small
role on was actually the first audition
that I went on for prime-time Network
show for NCIS los angeles so getting to
go on paramount and you know the ticket
had my name on it and getting brought in
there and I saw the other guys on the on
the sign-in sheet you know I'm IMDb in
him seeing what they have and they'd
been working for years like it's so cool
just to be in this room and then I got
it and so then of course I'm like this
is gonna happen every week welcome to
Hollywood belly and then obviously a
flat line and you hit a peak and but I
was that was just so cool because that
was about that was less than like eight
months of me being here so it kind of
just solidified putting hard work good
stuff kind of can habit and the fact
that I was in there meant that I had the
right kind of team working with me I
wasn't just you know another face in the
roster they were helping me get into the
right people and I had an amazing ratio
I was 14 one I was batting a thousand
after that first one which is always
good so that was a really proud moment
that was really cool and it was
something you know cuz you do so much
stuff that the people can't see or that
when they finally see it you barely
remember doing it sometimes because was
so long ago or you haven't told close
family members and friends that are
cheering for you so for something like
that to come along and to have people
that I know support me and understand
that I kind of just moved here but it is
a transition than to be able to watch
that it was really cool you know and
like I said it's a very small role but
it was where's my face on on TV you know
to my mom she was happy so that's you
know you prove it to her right oh that
is nice
you